yes I'm in here like this and he I told
him do whatever and he came in for a
bicep time
okay so I
mooved we're close okay we're close and
I'm
circling
[Music]
circling and that pressure that you're
going to feel right here that I felt
that that is
wrong this is where I had to be where he
falls into zero
pressure okay so here's zero
pressure you you can change the rate of
your rotation so here you feel how you
have my sent okay so project you'll
see so there I am I can you feel that
pressure whatever that was that I'm
pushable and I can change the rate you
see by the turn starts to change it okay
we'll go back get the pr there's the
pressure again right and my step changes
it you
see and then same pressure right here
this foot changes it you
see but your initial skill is to know
with your eyes where that is but if you
f up you can change your rotations and
things like like that but part of it is
that you're not here and press and pin
and in his case projectable
okay so here oh zero pressure he falls
into the
void zero pressure and once you get zero
pressure then you stick you stick on him
the P you
stick over
Pro boy
void void okay let's go
again hey uh when I do this I he's stuck
on me I don't need to
pull so I don't want to give back baby
you're going to smell that oh I could
throw him but if he changes his Center
once I had the center you see now I'm
trapped in
there's no need to do it P You're
Here
agressive okay let's go
getting
caught you're ahead you're running
away
[Music]
pulling I don't like to go fast I'm in
that hole
by tense
see
relax in
the
aggressive
here
externally I'm in the B
okay now
here see CU now you're going to pull
them now you're going to have to pull
them in the
hole okay try it again
okay so he's going to feel that I have
him I want him to get his Center back
get your Center back however you can got
it it's this chin drilled
now
good attack
aggressive there you go
good okay try Okay so boom I CL that and
you'll see this he's stalling
okay we'll have him regain push again
he's going to drive
again so if it's not
clear when I'm
here I'm going to get
him so he has he's got to regain his
center it's very much like this game
just like this game okay when he feels
that I have a center what are you going
to do you see how he pulled it back and
he grounded it okay same exact thing
here watch watch you pull it back and he
grounded it not going to work but he can
drive again
which was his initial attention so oh
there it comes
again
good boom avoid
again Bo
again on the line
[Music]
okay try
good okay so the one that I like cuz
there's going to be way more pressure
you pay attention go
back the first yield did not happen at
the same range so he drops he's there
okay now the second one is really close
you see that okay so when he drives on
me with his hands he's getting me stuck
and getting me stuck here you see that
so go back this way there just loosen it
a little it's no
different that when he presses to touch
my chest here I go I pass it to the
outside so same thing here on this
side when he when he drives and squeezes
me I yield this way and then it's start
on that elbow okay P here here
okay try it don't get stuck don't push
back yield come around it okay same same
in the game when whenever you're
training and you're allowing him the
ability to counter don't let it happen
dude don't there you go
okay the quicker you or the earlier in
the pressure values that you try your
move so here here I try my move here
he's going to get out of it really
really easily you're your y your overall
Yong values they do have to equal right
but they should be
higher and it'll give him less chance to
um to counter it so going using that
here when I go here I he's pressing I'm
grounding you see I I'm grounding to get
these high values in here because when I
yield I want him to fall into it I can't
do like IO la la land where I'm here and
I go like that the dude's going to
ground again come underneath it and come
out so it's not contesting because go
ahead and push you're internalizing
you're internalizing the energy is not
in you
okay so you can't do this this he'll
counter again you have to set them
up this one you can cuz it starts so far
out so I avoid
there okay try it again
[Music]
he and the same way when he had his
initial Onslaught and I voided here he's
got a lot of pressure here on the hand
you see so he collapsed my hand so I let
it collapse right on and I was able to
get it here but he collapsed the hand I
let it collapse
okay know we're fine I just want to
point out there it is he's he's trapped
I don't push back on that I let it go
and I yield it okay he's he would feel
that you feel that okay he's going to
counter it there he goes all right now
he's going to push on me and on yield
here it is right here I'm see okay so in
the same
way that I make it a adjustment to his
pressure you see to get that to go or in
the same way that my step out so take
that pressure push there it is that
pressure had I been able to step out you
see it
neutralize or take the pressure right
and I go this way and then that way I
I'm changing it with my steps my
rotations the right foot the left foot
okay same exact
way as I go
here don't have a universal technique
here okay so I increase the Y value
internalizing it you see and then I
decide what will work within this okay
don't have one that has the same thing
every time your arm is so low that I'm
using muscle to pick that up you see so
as I go I drive here
you see that difference yes and so I
don't I don't maybe get you to flip over
but I
definitely smash your face and then
break your arm and stomp on your head it
it's fine it works do you get it so obey
the values that you're feeling don't
have a technique okay try
[Music]
so the first rep rep one was an external
deviation rep two is an external bracing
you got two more to do
right external
deviation and then an
external bracing that had to go into an
external deviation
why do you think well first I'm doing
external because I can't do
internal but why do you think you got
away with the external
deviation on him and then on this one
you couldn't because he was able to uh
refine the center and push again yep
okay so he's more athletic more mobile
better condition conditioning and that's
a better opponent meaning they can
regain their dynamic equilibrium it
causes all kinds of freaking problems
for us who are all I have is my external
athletic capacity against him but if I
had the internal it does not doesn't
matter okay so there there is a a
martial viability aspect to the internal
and that is is meant to deal with
asymmetry uh between you and the
opponent okay all right I'll give you
one more a very common one so if if I
have one arm and I can't get out of it
in any other way like I just can't get
it got trapped and he's hugging his
elbow down on me do you see I can't get
it I'm not going to push on it it's just
not going to I'm not going to use it
what I'm going to do instead I'm going
to show you it's a cou net but it's with
my body so he's he's in that so I can't
get it out so I can't get the underhook
and I can't get the overhook that's why
he'll drop his elbow and pin it there
okay but this makes that whole thing
adhesional now I just add this side come
over
here okay so I he's pushing I'm ground
I'm ground vectoring get him deep into
the charge and then this hand I drop
that elbow okay so same thing here drop
the
elbow you smash it drop your elbow get
it up I'll get it up you see and I'll
snap it snap it you got to protect your
elbow there it is and now stop but now
the whole thing works
okay come back lower this a lot cuz the
lower this is the less High this has to
go and he's trying to drive it down so
lower this a
lot okay try
go okay so in all of these techniques
when you go it's more like he's driving
for that double leg it's done okay so he
has an initial Onslaught so you're you
have to hit the immediate x pattern
there push
there
that not this
[Music]
the skills fighter is going to realize
what you're doing to them okay they
tried it like oh he got lucky once
they'll try it
again and now they're not going to push
again do you understand he'll regain
your Center and you'll feel that like
okay the energy is off but it's not
driving on me and now this is where your
attm comes in okay so groin boom pop
boom I Tred there it is groin this way
hit boom
boom and it's
quick if your elbows hit it hit it
okay try it yeah
so
boy he
presses
yields okay he he regains he counters
all right and that's where my stuff has
to come from so we'll go back I'm going
to slow this down okay I'm doing the Kat
throw we recounts you see but he's not
driving on me and now this is contesting
you feel that you have to let it go you
have to let it go and that's your strike
right
there okay so we'll rewind the
film we'll do it
smooth he contest
boom get your
cery so wash the other hand
watch the other hand how quick there's
the counter boom comes in
here not here
transition right when you feel the
energy is it comes
in if you want you go here you feel this
and I avoid inside feel your pressure on
my hands you see that's the throwing
pressure I don't want to push this and
try to knee I'm not going to get in I
fit inside that pressure soft
in well there it is if I feel I can't
get it like he's I can't get in there
then do hands boom then
dry boom boom
[Music]
adop stop throwing regain get to put
your C
yes there it is Boom in in here
or stab
ballistic either way but there's no
energy acting on me he took off now he's
free now my strength can
go if I can get in I will
you're feeling where your energy is but
at no point should you be pushing here
pushing here smothering here it's all
moving in the UN spaces okay try it
again
it's a subtle thing that I did okay so
here's the Kut okay and then we're going
to add your inertia okay okay so you
drive your
inertia and you feel the yes the lock
that's there
you're
Nur here this is now my momentum I go
here like this hi you see hi you had no
momentum it doesn't lock you into place
turn get out of it there you
go so this is different when you drive
and when you don't drive I don't try to
do it you when there's no energy coming
forward that I can take and do and
triple or and triple forces you're
looking at gross manipulation of the
body so that's why this one goes this
way all right you see it's right here
right or the other
one that I did this way
do you get that yes okay so keep that in
mind don't go
into la la land where you see to does
this all
things and the person goes flying do do
do a forward roll for
me
now there's no energy so you're
twerking twerking you can do it
ballistically but there is a Force here
and it has to pass the a bottom Apex and
the top one has to pass the top Apex for
me to do it I
cannot hit
it okay
okay so you can do it ballistically here
in
place but if you paid attention the
bottom hand went to about 5:30 5:00 Top
Hand went to about 11 11:30 then you can
do it in place okay so when there's no
inertia and no no other than standing
inertia so there's no lateral momentum
then you're looking for gross
manipulations of the body and that means
you have one of your forces on one side
of the circle going past the bottom Apex
or past the top Apex and the other hand
on the other side of the circle doing
the same okay
[Music]
you jammed yourself first it's a feeling
not not an intellectual
[Music]
prediction so external contesting he had
more Force he displaced you
[Music]
push the head under make it a
manipulative
throw don't fight that right arm yield
to it or use it use the adhesion that's
there
good
good okay you pulled him into it
had you been bigger than you
no again big
man don't pick feel
[Music]
all big man
stuff don't don't take someone that's in
check so face down going down don't take
them back up and then take him the other
way that's just like keto masturbation
okay don't do it stupid
[Music]
all good
good come on
one of those uh other differences so no
no lateral inersia through the S plan
okay so when there is we don't break we
don't break the arms we use we use it
okay we use it as the lever so as he
pushes then I use it as a lever a lever
okay but when there's no inertia that's
when that becomes a break okay so it's
here C into the
face whether you're you have your your
overhook you see there's no inertia
under I'm I'm going to drive this head
into my knee as I break this so it goes
as I come through okay this
way or the over hook same thing it's
here boom snap here
okay and he he goes into this knee this
knee okay don't so picture that as
you're training you go he goes slow it's
right here boom don't throw it but show
it okay or the other one you're over
here you you end up here a lot so sheer
crack don't throw it but show it
okay for